thank you Thank You mr. speaker and I
thank the Prime Minister for a copy of
the statement before we met here this
afternoon we're an extremely serious and
unprecedented situation the government
has lost control of Invents and is in
complete disarray it's been evident for
weeks that the Prime Minister's deal did
not have the confidence of this house
yet she ploughed on regardless
reiterating this is the only deal
available can she be clear with the
house is she
seeking changes the deal or mere
reassurances does she therefore accept
the statement from the European
Commission at lunchtime saying that it
was the only deal possible
we will not renegotiate our position has
not changed
Ireland's tea shop Leo Vodka has said it
is not possible to renegotiate the Irish
border backstop stating that it was the
Prime Minister's own red lines that made
the backstop necessary so can the Prime
Minister be clear is she now ready to
drop further red lines in order to make
progress mr. speaker can the Prime
Minister confirm that the deal presented
to this house is not off the table but
will be represented with a few
assurances bringing back the same
botched deal either next week or in
January and can she be clear on the
timing will not change its fundamental
flaws and deeply held objections right
across this house which go far wider
than the backstop alone
mr. speaker this is a bad deal for
Britain a bad deal for our economy and a
bad deal for our democracy our country
deserves better than this the real
dammit the deal the deal damages our
economy and it isn't just the opposition
saying that the government's own
analysis shows this deal would make us
worse off if the Prime Minister cannot
be clear that she can and will agree
negotiate a deal then she must make way
[Applause]
[Music]
and if she is and mr. speaker if she is
going back to Brussels then she needs to
build a consensus in this house and
since it appears business has changed
for the next two days then it seems not
only possible but necessary that this
house debates the negotiating mandate
that the Prime Minister takes to
Brussels there is no point no point at
all in this Prime Minister bringing back
the same deal again which clearly does
not support the not supported by this
house mr. speaker we've endured two
years of shambolic negotiations red
lines which have been boldly announced
then cast aside we're now on our third
brexit secretary and it appears each one
of them has been excluded from these
vital negotiations we were promised a
precise and substantive document and got
a vague 26 page wish list and they
become the first government ever in
British history to be held in contempt
of parliament
the government is in disarray
uncertainty is building for business
people are in despair at the state of
these failed negotiations and concerned
about what it means about their jobs
their livelihood and their communities
and the fault for that lies solely at
the door of this shambolic government
[Applause]
the Prime Minister is trying to buy
herself one last chance to save this
deal if she doesn't take on board the
fundamental change is required then she
must make way for those who can
[Applause]